for today's classic interview we're
gonna go back to when I spoke to Nell
Bernstein back in June of 2014 and we
spoke specifically about child
incarceration this has been shoved back
into the forefront because of the Trump
family separations and child internments
and now spoke generally about child
incarceration outside of the specific
families at the border paradigm and I
think that's the sort of context that
I'm thinking of reviewing the interview
within let's go back to my interview
Nell Bernstein on child incarceration
from June of 2014 and just apply what
she said in this interview to what we
see going on right now every single day
at the us-mexico border I'm joined today
by Nell Bernstein who's the author of
burning down the house as well as all
alone in the world and a winner of the
White House champion of change award
today we're going to talk about
childhood incarceration in the United
States and now I think a good place to
start would be we've talked about adult
incarceration rates in the US and how
the US is up there with North Korea at
the top - in terms of incarceration
rates for adults if we look at child
incarceration rates where does the u.s.
rank well we're at an interesting
juncture right now because on the one
hand juvenile incarceration rates are
falling significantly they've dropped by
40 percent over the past 10 years at the
same time we are still the number one in
the u.s. I mean in the world for locking
up our kids by a factor of about seven I
think and what types of crimes are
getting juveniles in juvenile
incarceration facilities
well because juvenile incarceration so
often leads to adult incarceration the
important question for me is what type
of crimes lead to that first
incarceration right and there it's
almost always a low-level non-dangerous
offense sometimes you know graffiti and
loitering public drunkenness a marijuana
charge and then once you're in the
system endless probation violations
so not not the super predator that we
were led to believe and are there some I
don't know if crimes is the right word
or as you talked about them status
violations that only apply to juveniles
whereas for adults those those actions
wouldn't necessarily put them into
prison or jail
that's tricky also because there were
some legal changes meant to eradicate
locking kids up for status offenses
particularly running away but a lot of
kids I've met are locked up for
something that happened along with the
status events you know say you run away
and you sleep on the street and that's a
crime so I I think minor offenses some
of what your status offenses would be
the most accurate and for people who
don't know can you explain what a status
offense is and maybe give us some other
examples beyond running away sure a
status offense refers to your status as
a juvenile so it's something that would
not be illegal if you were an adult it's
only illegal because you're a kid so
running away underage drinking
truancy that's oh that's a big one you
know if I don't go to work it doesn't go
well for me but I don't go to jail my
kids make the same choice they're at
risk of a truancy charge that sort of
thing and you talked just very briefly
there about how the initial juvenile
incarceration often leads to
incarceration as an adult so I want to
take that in a couple of pieces because
I think there may be a couple of angles
to that first let's talk about the
sentences how can a juvenile
incarceration sentence turn into an
adult incarceration sentence well here's
what happens and I'm gonna give you a
little bit of background yes this is a
year that really shocked me eighty to
ninety percent of all American teenagers
in confidential interviews will tell you
that they've committed an offense
serious enough under the law to get them
locked up but most of them are not
locked up right they nobody notices they
get a pass
or maybe they get some kind of community
alternative and those kids grow up and
grow out of the impulsivity that led to
that original offense the portion of the
eighty to ninety percent of Americans
who are delinquent apparently who get
incarcerated they don't stay straight
through to adulthood but it's a very
traumatic experience many experienced
abuse physical abuse one in ten are
raped by guards and even without that
it's an environment in which sort of
fulfilling all the developmental tasks
of adolescents are pretty much
impossible and of course you develop a
criminal identity so that's why it's so
often spirals into adult incarceration
along with the stigma and label of being
a delinquent so let's talk a little bit
about that eighty to ninety percent of
American teenagers admit to some
activity that could be classified as a
crime but most will never actually spend
any time incarcerated with adult
incarceration we see the
disproportionate application of
sentences to those who are poor and to
minorities do we see those same factors
playing a role in what what percentage
or which ones of those American
teenagers end up spending time in prison
you've asked exactly the right question
and that's why I use that number pretty
frequently I think that some of us are
more familiar with statistics like a
black youth is five times more likely to
be locked up for the same charge and
with the same background as a white
youth so there are disproportionality
at every step of the system arrest
detention disposition or sentencing
parole probation at every juncture
researchers have found not just
disparate rates but differential
treatment based on your race and to a
lesser degree class so I think the
reason it's so important for me to share
that the great great majority of
teenagers get involved in delinquency is
that it really busts the myth that one
race is more criminal than another it
turns out as adolescents were all
delinquents we have poor judgment our
brains aren't fully developed and we
just need support you get through it and
let's explore that concept a little bit
so if we look at the cost and and we've
explored with adults that very often
when it comes to for example
homelessness it's actually cheaper to
provide housing and basic health care to
someone who's homeless then the social
costs over the course of a year from
that person being homeless we've talked
about adult education college education
is often less expensive than the cost of
incarceration
I'm guessing and I open it up to you to
tell me whether I'm right or wrong that
this is even Mystique wa li pronounced
when it comes to juveniles in terms of
education versus juvenile detention I
think it's much more pronounced
especially if you consider the
opportunity cost of a lost life we spend
eighty eight thousand dollars on average
to incarcerate a kid and ten thousand on
average to educate a single youth and
the kids know this the the message they
get from that is we'll spend anything to
contain you but nothing to cultivate you
and that's a very destructive message
when when the juvenile detention centers
are well I'll phrase it a different way
how prevalent is solitary confinement in
juvenile detention centers because
that's something that again on the adult
side we've talked about the destructive
effects long term of solitary
confinement and again from an outsider's
point of view I would imagine that
destructive effect would be even more
significant to a juvenile you're right I
mean the United Nations calls 15 hours
or more torture for adults and has no
any amount of time in solitary is
considered torture for children and
teenagers officially about a third of
juvenile detainees end up in some form
of solitary confinement
it's hard to measure because we don't
like to use that word we call it ad seg
or my favorite the reflection cottage in
among the kids I met and I talk to a lot
of kids I think I met maybe one or two
who hadn't experienced some form
solitary confinement or room isolation
one or two who had not experienced that
you're saying that's not empirical but
you know if you include things like
locking down a whole unit because
there's a shortage of teachers so you're
in your cell all day they had all
experienced that kind of intense
isolation and at least a third had
experienced formal solitary confinement
so a barren cell with maybe just a
blanket and now officially on the record
what are the reasons stated in some or
many of these cases how can we character
characterize the official explanations
for why this solitary confinement is
being assigned
well it's interesting Senator Durbin has
held a couple of hearings on this and
the official explanation given I think
by the head of the Federal Bureau of
Prisons and given by everyone under the
Sun was safety and security don't take
this away from us it's a tool that we
need but the kids to actually end up in
solitary for example then I heard this
over and over if you threaten worse if
you threaten suicide or act suicidal
you'll likely end up stripped naked and
tossed into a solitary cell where a
disproportionate number of suicides
unsurprisingly then occur if you're the
aggressor in a fight you could end up in
solitary if you're the victim of a fight
you could end up in solitary if they're
processing your papers you could end up
in solitary the number of reasons is
almost beyond reason really incredible I
want to remind everybody that the books
are burning down the house as well as
all alone in the world we've been
speaking with Nell Bernstein I recommend
both books now thank you so much for
being with us and really shedding light
onto something that many people may not
even be aware is going on
well thank you Oh is my pleasure